Donald Trump was interviewed this
morning on Fox News by brown-nosing
sycophant Maria Bartiromo
she was actually a pretty damn good
financial journalist 20 years ago I used
to watch her when I was getting into
stock trading early in high school and
now she is just a trump suck-up on the
Fox Business Network this interview
aired this morning but it was previously
recorded as I gather and the interview
was an absolutely unmitigated house of
horrors I want to go through some of the
most bizarre and disturbing moments with
you we could spend all day just looking
at this interview but I want to pick
just two important moments of Maria
Bartiromo gave Trump a softball
interview like she always does and yet
Trump is so clueless his ignorant is so
lethally weaponized that even Maria
Bartiromo couldn't save him with
softball questions so let's take a look
now to get this first thing out of the
way the goal posts are again being moved
on the coronavirus death toll now Trump
is talking about we're going to have
more than a hundred thousand deaths and
that is a great victory because of how
much worse it could have been check this
out and look at how casually Trump has
doubled the expected number of deaths
from just three weeks ago and yet it's
still calling it a victory thanks to him
we're gonna lose over a hundred thousand
perhaps in this country now in all
fairness that's at the bottom level of
the scale we were to lost two million we
were lost more if we did it a different
way but you're talking about a hundred
thousand more a little bit less more who
knows it's a terrible thing no so that
can't be replaced
we're spending trillions of dollars on
all of the damage economically
financially that it's caused so it it is
a terrible thing it's just an incredible
thing so he says that's at the bottom we
could have lost more than two million
people so there are two important
takeaways here yesterday we did a
debunking about we're now testing as
much as South Korea per capita important
to understand the the genesis of that
disinformation I want you to now
understand the genesis of this two
million thing that we hear a couple
things that are important to know
number one the goal posts have been
moved into the locker room and
they will soon be out in the parking lot
for a month or longer Trump was talking
about we may lose 60,000 people and
that's going to be a really great job
that we'll have done we blew past 60,000
deaths so Trump starts talking about
listen we could lose 70 or 80,000 people
we hit 70 and Trump started talking
about could be ninety to a hundred
thousand now Trump is cavalierly and
casually saying I'm gonna lose more than
a hundred thousand people and as long as
he always predicts a number slightly
larger than what we have eventually he's
going to be right eventually he will say
you know we're gonna lose 200,000 maybe
and we'll get to 195 and he'll say we
stayed under it forty percent of the
country Falls for it forty percent of
the country will hear this and believe
Trump knows what he's talking about no
matter how many times he shifts the
number more importantly here's what I
really want people to understand this
comparison of the death toll always to
2.2 or 2.5 million the deaths we could
have had if Donald Trump didn't act
understand that two million deaths is if
literally nothing is done now this would
be impossible because governors do
excuse me do things there is not going
to be any scenario where governors were
doing nothing in fact the governors did
stuff before Trump did we saw stay at
home orders and starting to quarantine
and and the like at the state level
before Trump did anything so when Trump
says understand we're two million comes
from two million is we have 331 million
people in the country 70% of the country
gets the virus that would get us to hurt
immunity if 70 percent got the virus
that means about 230 million people get
the virus we expect an infection
fatality rate not a case fatality rate
an infection fatality rate of about 1%
1% of 231 million is 2.3 million so that
is literally no mitigation so when Trump
says listen we're gonna lose a hundred
thousand instead of two million thanks
to me it's a worthless comparison that
says nothing at all about Donald Trump's
response the important point is we're
now at 85,000 deaths
we're
expected to hit a hundred thousand in
about a week or ten days the numbers
will continue climbing but Trump will
claim victory no matter the death number
because he has set 2.2 2.3 million as
the bar that he is keeping us below next
clip clip of Trump exhibiting such a
poor understanding of trade economics
and manufacturing and foreign policy
that he actually says if we end our
relationship with China
our financial relationship our
relationship of trade we would save five
hundred billion dollars
I'm gonna play the clip Trump seems to
think if we just we stop importing and
exporting with China we quote save 500
billion take a look at this you spoke
with DG Jinping I have a very good
relationship but I just right now I
don't want to speak to him because you
know senator cotton was saying maybe we
should be limiting the amount of visas
that we give to students who want to
study things like there are many things
and AI there are many things we could do
we could do things we could cut off the
whole relationship now if you did what
would happen you'd say 500 billion
dollars if you cut off the whole
relationship look at what point does it
and I said this for years I said it with
other countries also you know China's
not the only country ripping us off this
is one of the most incoherent things
that Trump has actually said in his
presidency and I'm gonna explain to you
why first there's this idea that we we
save 500 billion I believe what Trump is
talking about is our trade deficit with
China as recently as a couple of years
ago I had trouble finding the numbers
from from last year but a couple of
years ago we had a five hundred billion
dollar trade deficit with China what
that means is we import 500 billion more
in products from China than we export to
China we have a deficit of five hundred
billion dollars so it seems that Trump
who has the economics understanding of a
fruit fly thinks if we cancel all trade
we end up at zeros meaning the 500
billion deficit goes away and it's like
save
five hundred billion dollars now this is
not how trade and economies work the 500
billion trade deficit with China would
go away if we were to stop all trade
with China maybe it doesn't even really
work that way but then we would have a
massive deficit in terms of the products
that we all take for granted and then
prices would explode on a whole bunch of
stuff because our economy is based on
cheap stuff from China
we would have to there's a couple
options if we stopped trade with China
on the one side for importing we either
have to import from other countries the
stuff we get from China which just
shifts the trade deficit and it would
explode demand for these products in the
new countries we deal with bringing up
the prices that doesn't sound too good
for American businesses and individuals
if we decide to manufacture all of the
stuff we get from China internally I
mean it would be impossible but imagine
that we did it would take years to build
both supply chains but imagine we did it
stuff would cost way way more because
the reason we get these things from
China is because they're cheaper and our
economy is based on that and then you
also have to remember a ton of our
businesses would fail if we stopped
exporting to China as Trump says which
would save us 500 billion as he puts it
all of these American businesses that
are exporting to China go under what do
you think the economic impact would be
of that unemployment on disposable
incomes on the stock prices as Trump
might see it of these companies this is
so absurd and crazy and it is almost
inconceivable that an American president
would have such a lack of basic economic
understanding and Maria Bartiromo
through no fault of her own she's a
disastrous Trump brown-noser through no
fault of her own she has exposed Trump
in this interview as completely and
utterly clueless not just on coronavirus
we knew that but also clueless on
economics to a degree that even those of
us following this for the last few years
would arguably be stunned and appalled
by no understanding whatsoever we're
gonna have more about this on the David
Pakman show Instagram that's david
pakman show on Instagram also on my
personal Instagram
it is planting day today we are past the
frost here in Boston follow me at David
Pakman on Instagram to follow the urban
gardening adventure a lot happening
there in the next 24 hours I'm gonna
come clean with you guys I'm sick of
being laughed at even though I didn't
vote for the guy I'm sick of being the
laughingstock on this planet the entire
planet is laughing at us making fun of
us we are the punchline of every global
political joke because of Donald Trump
now his followers may not know or they
may not care Trump may keep telling
himself and us that we are the envy of
the world including on our handling of
coronavirus and testing and everything
else but it's not true and I am really
embarrassed by it because it's shameful
to be this laughingstock the whole world
thinks were a joke because Trump is a
joke and Appelbaum our rights that in
China the official Chinese news agency
is pushing videos making fun of us
claims by Donald Trump that it's only a
flu claims that are embarrassing to go
back and look at today that video has
gone viral in Indonesia they wrote in
disbelief about Trump proposes
disinfectant injection and UV rays to
treat Kovan 19 in France reports say the
rantings of dr. Trump ridiculing him
once again in South Africa an article
promotes the horrors of US president
Donald Trump leaving people stunned and
confused with his bizarre suggestion
that disinfectant and ultraviolet light
could be used to treat the virus in Peru
a newspaper article called attention to
dr. deborah birx 'as visibly pained
expression as trump wondered aloud about
bleach injections to treat corona virus
and meanwhile as the world laughs Trump
insists everybody looks up to us
everybody looks up to him on coronavirus
and testing and everything we're doing
here is Trump at a recent event making
this case and we're going to do a job
like like
nobody's seen before and I spoke with
Angela Merkel today I spoke with Prime
Minister Abbey of Japan I spoke with
many of the leaders over the last four
or five days and so many of them almost
all of them I would say all of them not
everybody want to admit it but they ovo
us as the world leader and they're
following us you look at what we've done
with ventilators we started this is one
of two things either a clueless person
saying something that they believe to be
true which is not which is obviously not
true or it's gaslighting it is making
someone believe is making someone
question the reality by telling them
something that is completely
disconnected from fact if any of them
are looking to us if other countries are
looking to the United States it's to
avoid doing what we did because almost
every country has handled coronavirus
better than we have Russia now is
becoming a mess it's a mess in Russia
and they're rapidly becoming one of the
epicenters Russia maybe handle this
worse than the United States we don't
know yet it's early brazil is becoming a
major cesspool of coronavirus
transmission we know about dryer ball
scenarios skeptical attitude towards the
virus India is growing ly growing a
problem not growing Lee is increasingly
a problem when it comes to the virus
we'll see if they are able to turn it
around but otherwise everybody would be
looking to us to not do what we've done
they're not impressed with us we're not
the leader here they're laughing at us
now there's a new report which says it's
actually worse than just laughter
laughter would be one thing there's a
new report that says the world is
actually despairing because countries
that have become used to seeing the us
at the table figuring out solutions now
we're seeing the u.s. as completely
useless because of Donald Trump European
critics say it's not just that Trump
isn't helping like the United States
normally does Trump is eroding respect
for the United States and getting in the
way of global cooperation and solutions
this has real-world implications and I
want to be clear about that this is not
a haha Trump
segment our global position is being
destroyed by this man electing Trump in
2016
instantly called into question the US as
being a serious country but maybe it was
a mistake if Trump is reelected it will
cement the United States as a joke and
there's no other way to say it
if that happens we are going to have to
face the reality that American voters
are as much of a problem as Trump
himself and the people Trump hires now
we've suspected this for a while we've
talked about it for a while but it will
be the the last confirmation if we
reelect Donald Trump we will know that
the disaster actually afflicts 60 maybe
even 70 million people who may vote for
Trump in November of 2020 the world is
laughing a lot of people actually take
pleasure in that Trump astaire about our
reputation around the world or they
simply tell themselves our reputation is
great but this is not good and it must
be stopped as many of you may know I've
mentioned I've been listening to the
Howard Stern Show for more than 20 years
and he has had recently increasingly
interesting comments about Donald Trump
including this week and the the back
story is that Donald Trump and Howard
Stern sort of used to be acquaintances I
don't know that I'd say friends but
Donald Trump would regularly appear on
Howard Stern's show for years he would
say many outrageous things he would rate
women on scales from one to ten you know
all sorts of different stuff they don't
talk anymore Howard Stern vociferous Lee
supported Hillary Clinton in 2016 and
from what I gather Trump and Howard
Stern have not spoken since that time
and Howard Stern had an interesting take
about the relationship between Trump and
his own supporters when he did a show
earlier this week on Sirius XM radio and
the gist of it is that Trump supporters
are mostly people that Trump despises
bearing in mind that Donald Trump grew
up rich in New York and his supporters
overwhelmingly are the types of folks
that Trump would never want at
mar-a-lago or at his own hotels or
around him or whatever the case may be
that that is the constituency
that has disproportionately made up
Trump space rural white Midwestern and
southern Americans for example I think
you get the gist of it not doesn't apply
to everybody but let's check out the
comments and a discuss the oddity in all
of this is the people Trump despises
most love him the most think about it
the the the the people who are voting
for Trump for the most part they're not
people he wants oh my god he wouldn't
even know I'm in a hotel he be disgusted
with them he doesn't want to go look at
mar-a-lago see if there's any people
that look like you I'm talking to you in
the audience that the Trump voter who
you know idolizes the guy he disappears
you despises you you're someone to grab
by the [ __ ] if you're hot
I know Donnell I know him very well
and I don't hate Donald I hate you for
voting for him I don't hate Donald
battles doing his thing I hate you from
voting for him for not having an
intelligence not able to see what's
going on with the coronavirus not able
to see what the Justice Department is
doing I hate you
want you here I want to build a wall and
throw you the
I do I'm for a wall
the Mexican for you
that's how I feel now don't call me and
start arguing with me Howard you're a
jerk you're a Libertad or whatever it is
you call I ain't no lip tar trust me I'm
hardly a liberal
hardly you have no idea how no
non-liberal I am this is pretty spot-on
in some ways in the sense that they just
don't get it it is true that the Trump
voter typically just doesn't get it but
this is not unique to Donald Trump and I
think it bears a little more exploration
and to understand this you have to think
about personal versus in-group
priorities personal versus in-group
frameworks the 2010 Tea Party is an
example that I've talked about before
social psychologist Jonathan Hite talked
about this we interviewed him on the
program year or so ago maybe a little
longer and he's written about this
extensively he wrote about it in the
book the righteous mind which if you
don't have to agree with everything that
Jonathan height writes but and I don't
agree with it 100% but he writes about
this extensively and the gist is when
you look at individual versus group
framing there is a very long history of
people acting in ways that don't seem to
be optimized at their individual level
but are optimized for their group and as
a result they perceive that it will
confer benefits to them and the best way
to think about it is with an example
um you look at the 2010 Tea Party all
right 2010 Tea Party ran on lower taxes
for the rich don't tread on me right so
lower government regulations lower
government involvement don't regulate
business nearly as much essentially
allow more pollution lower fuel
efficiency standards more oil drilling
fewer welfare benefits and social
programs you look at who was
overwhelmingly supporting the Tea Party
you look at the districts where the Tea
Party candidate won sometimes against an
incumbent sort of more traditional
Republican it was overwhelmingly people
who were never going to be rich and
benefit from those tax cuts for the rich
whose taxes weren't going to go down if
Tea Partiers got their way who live in
places that would be ravaged by the very
industrial pollution that the tea party
would have allowed by eliminating
government regulations and taking this
leis affair more libertarian approach so
you might be able to just simply say
we're on the Left we we we understand
what these dumb people don't these are
just stupid people trick
into voting against their own best
interests and that is so the wrong
approach they may have been tricked but
it's not that they don't understand the
policies of the Tea Party they
understand in many cases what the
policies are they've identified that
those are the policies that their group
favors even if they don't immediately
see or believe that at any point they
will personally benefit they believe
that there will be a sort of
trickle-down benefit because this is
what their group wants and that is why
they are voting for these policies by
voting for the Tea Party they may not
even know why they may not realize that
their group has actually been taken over
by elites who want to use them as a tool
to achieve what's good for them rather
than for the actual voters who are just
gonna get peanuts or crumbs but they
understand the policies and in many
cases they've identified the policies as
this is what our team or our group wants
and I'm going to vote with the orthodoxy
of the group I'm a part of apply that to
the Trump voter and you see that there's
a similarity in many cases we've
categorized Trump voters before some of
them don't actually understand what from
brunt ran on they don't they have no
clue what the policies are or they don't
understand them could be because of
cognitive limitations it could be people
who lack education and critical thinking
skills simply people who don't watch the
news and just sort of like herd vote for
Donald Trump there's people who voted
for Trump because they have a limited
understanding of the facts but a lot of
Trumpets do understand the policies of
Trump and even if they don't see how it
helps them specifically they're part of
the group except that the people really
in Trump's group which is what Howard
Stern points out are people who hang out
at mar-a-lago and a lot of these Trump
supporters I would say the overwhelming
majority are people that free politics
Trump would never be associated with
would be seen as would be seeing as
people that are fundamentally beneath
him most Trump voters are people Trump
wouldn't be caught dead with except as
part of a photo-op or rally now that
he's a politician now where I disagree
with Howard Stern is this entire you
know I hate his
orders for voting for him and their
their dumb that's an understandable
visceral reaction particularly when you
see the way that Donald Trump's
presidency has ravaged so many aspects
of society and culture and the economy
and the u.s. standing around the world
and on and on and on but as a practical
matter it falls under the umbrella of
what I'd call vote shaming and it's it's
plenty interesting to do for a broadcast
show and it's it's compelling and
salacious but I don't think it's a good
way to get people to reconsider their
votes now at the same time I don't think
that Trump is going to be defeated by
convincing his supporters not to vote
for him I've said before I don't believe
that that's the strategy I think the
strategy is mobilize your key
constituencies and get people out to
vote who already agree with you but that
being said I don't see any particular
advantage did the approach of if you
voted for Trump you're dumb and I hate
you for it certainly we should
acknowledge that we believe it was a
mistake it was the wrong decision but I
don't know that there's much to gain
from this general umbrella term of what
I would call vote shaming as much as it
might be the obvious visceral emotional
reaction on our side we're going to keep
talking about this and the other stories
from today's show on the David Pakman
show instagram at david pakman show also
yesterday on my Instagram I showed
everybody my cukes
I have a whole bunch of cucumber plants
which I thought were dead I thought
these seeds are dead these aren't going
to germinate I've got no sprouts but I
have sprouts now and I showed my sprouts
to everybody yesterday you can check it
out on my Instagram at David Pakman
nothing better than a coronavirus
Victory Garden as I'm calling it even if
the victory is gonna take a while to get
here I check it out we'll take a quick
break and be back after this donald
trump's world is crumbling around him he
doesn't understand anything he's furious
all the time he doesn't understand how
viruses work how vaccines work how masks
work how Lysol and bleach and isopropyl
alcohol work and he spent his entire
weekend tweeting everything from
retweeting his own tweets to pushing
queuing
on conspiracy theories to attacking
Barack Obama and the media at one point
listen to these numbers Trump sent 52
tweets and retweets in an hour that is
almost one tweet per minute Trump sent
more than 50 tweets over the weekend
about the Russia investigation Trump
sent over a hundred tweets in a single
day I am NOT going to subject you to all
of these the content is mostly
irrelevant for our understanding of how
hard this dude is failing but check out
some of these are completely out of
control man without common sense or
inhibitions retweeting endless
conspiratorial attacks on Barack Obama
and the FBI for the Russia probe we have
some of them on the screen the content
is mostly irrelevant these are the
rantings of a madman and that's how they
should be interpreted continuing about
one tweet per minute sometimes three or
four or even five tweets in a single
minute Trump even retweeting his own
tweets from hours earlier we can't
possibly go through hundreds of Donald
Trump's tweets nor would it make sense
to the content again is not really the
focus here but the gist of this so that
you understand the next wave of
propaganda the gist of what we saw over
the weekend is that Donald Trump is now
renewing his claim and his focus on the
entire Russia investigation being a
calculated illegal conspiracy involving
Barack Obama to end his presidency and
unfortunately and this is why as I spoke
about in the last segment I fear that
Trump is somehow gonna figure out a way
to get himself reelected this could be
the perfect distraction from the fact
that almost 81 thousand people as of
this morning have already died from
coronavirus and that number continues to
climb
last week Donald Trump's Justice
Department decided they're not going to
go forward with the prosecution of
Michael Flynn Donald Trump's disgraced
former national security adviser
understand that Flynn pleaded guilty and
the Justice Department has decided in
what is one of the most overtly corrupt
actions of the Trump presidency
hey we aren't going to move forward the
case against him isn't that strong he
pleaded guilty so now they're using this
absolutely corrupt decision by Trump's
Attorney General William bar to try to
revitalize the case that the entire
Russia investigation was bogus illegal
it was Obama's illegal plan and on and
on and on Fox News regularly over the
weekend using the term bombshell so
we're gonna talk about a bunch of
different things here number one I'd
briefly on the Michael Flynn thing if
Donald Trump had pardoned Michael Flynn
it would have been another one of these
sick corrupt elements of Donald Trump's
cronyism and nepotism and everything he
said that he would root out that he
actually embodies but it would have been
less concerning then Trump's Attorney
General coming in and saying about a
case that was built up over years were
you achieved a guilty plea yeah we're
not gonna prosecute that anymore that's
a level of corruption involving the
Justice Department that is actually far
scarier than Trump simply pardoning his
friend or his guy and will have more
time to talk about that a few other
things that that we need to talk about
first of all a hundred and twenty five
tweets in one day fifty two tweets in an
hour
people who work fast food people who
teach school people who work in
factories me everybody I know who has a
job none of them have time to tweet
fifty two times in an hour even people
whose job it is to tweet typically don't
tweet fifty two times in an hour this is
not normal behavior it has to be stopped
and there's only one way to stop it and
you know it and I know it and it's
happening about five-and-a-half months
from now number two the Republican
Senate must be punished for this in
November I know that there's a lot of
focus on Trump but if it weren't for the
Republican Senate Trump would have
already been removed or at least could
have been removed remember
that impeachment trial last week I got a
call about you know what's more
important than moving Trump or defeating
Republican senators in the fall you get
to vote in both you don't have to pick
I'm voting in the presidential or I'm
voting in the Senate election it's in
all of the above situation Republicans
must be punished they aren't just
complicit they're actively involved
there's a whole bunch of Republican
senators martha mcsalley susan collins
cory gardner you know we've talked about
the whole list of them they could all be
removed in addition to removing Donald
Trump and then lastly we're in the midst
of a hundred-year pandemic and Trump is
failing in his handling of that pandemic
and he tweeted a hundred more than a
hundred times in one day if anyone did
anything like this at work if a
firefighter was tweeting while a house
was burning down if an airline pilot was
tweeting during an emergency landing
anybody else would be fired from this
they would be removed from their job
depending on what the costs were of
their distraction they would be
criminally prosecuted and we need to
make sure that Trump is held accountable
in the only possible way that he's going
to be held accountable I believe part of
what might have set Trump off this
particular weekend is Barack Obama
lashing out at Trump about his handling
of coronavirus and that's what I want to
talk about next I've got a great little
lesson for all of you today in
historical revisionism and gaslighting
put together you might be familiar with
Caylee Mac and Annie she's Donald
Trump's latest press secretary she has
done a few press briefings lying
regularly for Donald Trump she says that
Trump is the best president ever she
justifies anything he does and says
she's the epitome of a true brown-nosing
sycophant but she was not always like
this
as far as Trump is concerned because
back during the 2016 Republican primary
she said Trump is hateful and says
racist things we have the video let's
take a look at it how sick of polls
people in New Hampshire right now
probably very sick especially when they
see that Donald Trump is number two and
doesn't deserve to be there the GOP
doesn't need to be turning away voters
on isolating them we need to be bringing
them into the tent Donald Trump is the
last person who's going to do that Haley
this is your guy he's number two in the
polls hey I don't want to claim this guy
the fact that the Republican Party is
now having to claim him it's both
unfortunate and to me inauthentic what's
the expiration date then on a racist
statement to me a racist statements a
racist statement I don't like what
Donald Trump said I don't like what Al
Sharpton says and at what point does it
expire and become something that BK
Trump is racist Trump is hateful she
doesn't like it she doesn't like him now
here's the real payoff Caylee was asked
about these past statements by reporter
Jimmy SH Alcindor during a recent press
briefing and her answer is the epitome
of an Orwellian look the other way sort
of answer she says you know I mistakenly
thought Trump was racist because I was
reading CNN headlines at the time this
is her explanation take a look at it
glad you asked that because for about
first four weeks of the election I was
watching CNN and I was naively believing
some of the headlines that I saw on CNN
and I'm actually not going to read the
headline so I very quickly took came
around supported the president in fact
CNN hired me I was on many eight on one
panels where I proudly supported this
president who I believe is one of the
best presidents it's not the best
president this country will ever have
but I would encourage the individual who
did that analysis of my past rather than
focusing on me he really should be
focused on some of the very guest CNN
chose to have on their network he should
be focused on I mean my over here Jim
Jim clapper who said you know 10 days
before he privately told investigators
there was no evidence of collusion okay
so her notes for this question include
attacks on CNN guests
and we can stop it right there her
argument is when I said what I said
about Donald Trump when I said he was a
hateful racist and all that stuff i was
wrong because i fell for CNN headlines i
no longer fall for CNN headlines like i
did back then how easy to trick her
though right can she really be trusted
if she so easily fell for supposedly
fake headlines from CNN and do we trust
her judgment if she took a job with with
CNN as she says despite believing that
they are fake news now I really need you
to understand something
Trump is see that and they think it
makes sense trumpets are thrilled with
Caylee Mackin Annie they're gleefully
cheering how she's been owning the media
with these huge alpha take downs of the
biased fake news press corps it is
literal nonsense which only calls into
question her own judgment if she fell
for supposedly fake headlines and the
trumpets love it they regularly tweet
about how Caylee Mackin annie is just
crushing these reporters during press
briefings now on principle this
explanation is absurd but of course it's
not just about headlines she came up
with these opinions on her own it's not
that she was repeating things like I
know you all know that it's a dumb
explanation but she was coming up with
stuff on her own that was anti-trump
I'll give you an example on August 6th
of 2015 she tweeted everyone seems to
have a plan except Trump live during a
Republican primary debate she didn't get
that from CNN that's her opinion she
came up with that she volunteered it so
do I think for a second that Caylee
Mackin Annie truly believes Trump is the
best president in history I don't
believe it for a second do I think she's
willing to say anything at any time in
order to justify her own career and try
to advance her own interests which right
now includes impressing Donald Trump and
having this national platform of press
briefings of course and every time she
tweets every time she speaks to the
press that's exactly what she's doing
and then maybe most importantly is it
and the answer is on trumpets it is
trumpets are hugely impressed with her
every time she does one of these joke
press briefings Don jr. retweets it and
talks about it a whole bunch of people
even people that are only sort of
tangentially involved in politics that I
know who are friends with on Facebook
and a sort of centrist right have been
posting clips of Caylee Mackin Annie and
how great and amazing everything she's
doing is it's concerning it's extremely
concerning because she seems to be
convincing the exact people that needed
to feel like here's someone who can
actually hold their own given that Trump
can't
during these press briefings and Caylee
Mackin annie is doing it for them again
the world is laughing we on the left
think it's absolutely crazy what she's
doing but the people she's trying to
impress seem impressed very much so
this is super interesting and maybe not
completely surprising to you White House
data has now leaked which shows that the
White House knows that infections are
spiking in rural Trump voting areas
while they continue to decline in some
of those early hit disproportionately
urban blue voting areas and the growing
political divide that has long permeated
the country when it comes to attitudes
towards coronavirus as we know Democrats
much more likely to be taking the virus
seriously than Republicans Democrats
much more likely to be staying at home
than Republicans Democrats much more
likely to be wearing masks than
Republicans that now which has been a
political divide for some time is being
reflected in the case and death growth
rates now the trumpets will say listen
most of the deaths are still in blue
areas these liberal cities like New York
City and the surrounding New Jersey of
towns and cities Chicago Detroit Boston
now of course those places also have in
common that they are very dense cities
with huge numbers of direct flights to
and from China and Europe so that
explains why those places were early
hubs and why they were places with
significant infection early before we
had any testing and before we knew much
about the prevalence in the spread of
coronavirus but in terms of percentages
which is really where you have to look
if you want to evaluate a virus it's
called viral spread for a lot for a
reason we are now seeing that most of
those early hotspots on a percentage
basis are actually on a decline whereas
some of the fastest growth rate spots
are for example Texas Florida and
Georgia
now just to put some numbers to it check
out the case growth rates yesterday
these are not raw numbers what you want
to look at is the rate of growth which
is a trajectory okay you look at
yesterday Tennessee Virginia Texas
Georgia and Florida all had dramatically
larger case growth rates than
Massachusetts and New York Massachusetts
right at one percent New York at 0.43%
Tennessee three point five percent
growth rate yesterday and so what you
have to understand is that over time the
raw numbers are going to spike you look
at Tennessee in cases and you might say
oh okay well they went from you know 600
to 650 cases but if that rate continues
it becomes a huge hotspot very very
quickly so that gets us to this leaked
data the White House has a number of
slides which have leaked that show that
this is a trend the White House is aware
of you've got rates decreasing in 14
states rates increasing in nine states
but 27 states don't even have enough
testing yet that we can say for sure
that all of the cases are even close to
being counted accurately but here's
where it gets really interesting the
state level data may not really be
enough to underscore this dr. Burks and
others for a while now have been saying
we really need to look at counties you
need to look at counties to see what's
going on that helps to separate urban
versus rural
it helps us separate parts of states
from each other it turns out that when
you look at the county level the biggest
spikes are happening in rural Trump
voting counties in places like Kansas
and tennis
some of those places have seen case
growth rates of more than a thousand
percent in a single week there are rural
Trump counties in Missouri Nebraska
Minnesota Wisconsin which lean heavily
trump the counties do where cases have
grown 400% all but one of the top ten
growth counties in the last week were
trump counties in 2016
dr. John Ross who's a professor at
Harvard Harvard Medical School tweeted
about the same quote the fastest rising
areas in the US for kovat cases are very
white and very Trumpy according to this
slide somebody leaked to NBC News this
is why I do not believe that Trump's
strategy of just normalizing the deaths
and pretending we've won is going to
work it could work for some time there's
no question about it because right now
the growth rates are very high in a lot
of these Trump counties but the raw
numbers are still small if you go from a
hundred to 200 new cases per day it's a
hundred percent increase but it's still
only 200 cases it's not going to get as
much attention particularly when a lot
of times people are sorting the data by
most new cases today which will favor
states with larger populations and
states with early infections but if then
you go from 200 new cases a day to 400
to 800 to 1600 and then cumulative
cumulative Lee you're talking about a
huge number of infections so what that
says to me is the Trump strategy of
saying we won we've prevailed we're on
the decline
we've got testing we've got everything
the economy is going to reopen third
quarter will be transitional fourth
quarter is gonna be amazing 2020 one's
gonna be the best in history this type
of stuff it ignores that if these growth
rates continue another 30 days and we
said this 10 days ago and now a lot of
these states are the leaders in growth
rate if it's another 30 days of this you
are going to have very red states that
presumably local news is still going to
report on cases and deaths national news
is going to point to these states as the
new hot spots I don't believe that it is
viable for Trump to simply pretend
everything is fine until November
if indeed these places continue spiking
also interesting somebody leaked this
data that means that someone inside the
White House and inside or close to the
task force I don't mean like dr. Burks
but there's so much staff that's
associated they probably decided to leak
this because they realized they need to
because of what the public position of
Trump has been you see Trump go out and
say cases are going down everywhere and
then inside the task force they have
slides would say that's not true and the
places where it's growing the fastest or
mostly Trump counties
you've got Fox News broadcasting you
know it's time to go and open and get
back to work but a ton of their
employees are still working from home
what's being said publicly is not
matching up with the policies that a lot
of places are putting in place Trump
continues to say we don't need to worry
about testing and tracing things are
good to go everything's going down and
yet the White House over the last 72
hours has put in place a mandatory masks
policy and daily testing for more and
more people other than Trump and pens of
course they're not wearing masks so they
are very clearly saying one thing and
doing something very different when it
comes to the policy behind the scenes
meantime I am very pleased to see that
here in Massachusetts we had very small
case growth rate for about the last 10
days deaths yesterday were at their
lowest since April 4th which is about 40
days ago Louis deaths and 40 days was
yesterday in Massachusetts that's really
really good to see and we're expecting
some new guidance probably in the next
48 hours from Massachusetts governor
Charlie Baker who's not been perfect
he's been late on a bunch of stuff but
he's been far earlier than more than
half of the country's governors we'll
see what continues to happen in the
early infection blue states like New
York New Jersey Massachusetts California
Illinois and then we're going to be able
to compare and contrast that was place
with places that never really closed at
the state level cities may have done
things and that have been very quick to
reopen we're going to know in the next
20 or 30 days exactly what the
repercussions of that are early data are
that it's not going to be particularly
pretty